word quickly spread on Friday morning
that residents of Lahaina the historic
Maui Town largely destroyed by the fire
would be allowed to return at noon there
was a 10 pm curfew a massive line of
cars rapidly formed this traffic jam
extends 25 kilometers in that direction
towards Lahaina but also as far as the
eye can see and the other direction
along this Western Coastal Highway
some waiting in line Express their
disbelief not just at the lack of a
warning as the wildfires approached
their Town earlier in the week but the
lack of information since
[Music]
we had family members that were burned
alive in cars
I have family that's still stuck with no
gas no water no power no way to tell our
family in the mainland that we're safe I
was born and raised here for 21 years
this is all I ever known I watched my
whole Hometown burned down
over a thousand buildings have been
destroyed many in the oceanfront core of
what was Hawaii's capital in the early
19th century before U.S colonization
many of these areas will remain off
limits to Residents as the search
continues for human remains
Hawaii's governor confirmed that those
who died did so in the open as they
tried to escape
thousands remain in shelters many have
nothing left I lost my condo my Jeep my
laptop my cell phone uh everything I
ever owned for 40 years that I lived in
Lahaina and it remains unclear how this
town that just last week had a
population of 13 000 will rebuild
chabertansi Al Jazeera Maui